Good morning, John!
You were recently making fun of my new hairstyle.
Which is fine, because we're brothers, and
that's what brothers do.
But coming right back at you John, I gotta
say WHAT IS THIS?
WHAT?
WHY?
Come on, we've been doing this for 8 years,
do you have no sense of composition?!
You gotta bunch of stuff on the wall over
here, nicely placed and visually interesting
without being distracting - AND THEN BWOM,
NOTHING.
Blank space, baby.
Help us John, help free us from the scourge
of the nothing, Artax is dead and you need
to name the childlike empress, BASTION, CALL
MY NAME!
Are the new viewers gone yet?
Some friends of mine, they have a YouTube
channel where they play board games while
being drunk.
They play this improv game called "That's
not my name".
You know the song that this is based on, [singing]
They call me hell, they call me Janet, they
call me Stacey, they call me Earl...
That song?
I don't know what the actual names are.
The idea of the game is you go around in a
circle and you sing that song, with the "That's
not my name / that's not my name" in it, and
then the next person has to do it and they
have to come up with different names to put
in, it's really fun.
So if ever you're bored that's just a, it's
a fun thing to do, Katherine and I do it all
the time.
[singing] They call me Brian, they call me
Nargle, the call me Amber, they call me Jeff,
that's not my name.
None of those are my names.
I used to think that butterflies were pretty
much just caterpillars that had had some modifications
made to them.
But it turns out that caterpillars actually
just turn into this, like, liquid, soupy,
organic goop inside of the cocoon and then
reform entirely into butterflies.
And that's not even the weird part.
The weird part is that caterpillars can be
taught to fear smells and then they turn into
that goop, turn into butterflies, and the
butterflies remain afraid of those smells.
Office tour!
Michael: 2015 is red-lined.
Hank: You guys work so hard.
Michael: I know.
Hank: Snacks!
Caitlin.
Caitlin: Hi!
Hank: This is Callie Awesomesauce; he needed
to go in a different tank 'cause he's a murderer.
That was too long.
Duncan: Yeah.
Hank: I'm going to cut all of that.
Duncan: It's gonna be like "Hah!"
Hank: I'm going to use that.
Crash Course studio.
This is my pile of shirts.
I always need one of those.
SciShow.
Hi everybody.
No way we can see all of you with that speed.
Stefan: Oh.
Hank: There's too many of you!
There are 40 Nic Cages in here?
Sarah: One there.
Hank: You just have one?
Hailey: Yeah, that's all I need really.
Hank: Glad you keep them close by though.
That's creepy, Ah-ha that's awful.
Stupid Crash Course is up the stupid stairs
now.
Hi, Abby.
Giving people a tour of our s... offices.
Nick: The thank you video we need from you?
Hank: No!
No!
I should be doing that though.
Hi Blake.
I'm just showing everybody the office.
Good job!
They're so quiet.
Tim: Why are you doing this?
Hank: VidCon!
Ken: When we say get out poop man, we don't
mean you.
[Music]
Hank: I was recently thinking about Vladimir
Putin and how he's probably not just ordered
people to be killed, but actually physically
killed people himself, and then I thought,
you know, probably, US presidents have also
killed people, so I looked it up.
And it turns out lots of US presidents have
killed people, but mostly in combat.
There are only two US presidents who definitely
killed people outside of combat situations.
And they are: Andrew Jackson, who killed a
guy in a duel, but only after that guy shot
him in the chest, a bullet that would remain
near his heart for the rest of his life, and
Grover Cleveland, who as the sheriff of Erie
County personally carried out two executions
of murderers, even though he could have paid
a deputy ten dollars apiece to do it for him.
Grover Cleveland, very Ned Stark of you.
They call me Bobby, they call me quiet, they
call me nice guy, they call me fancy, that's
not my name.
John, I think my hair looks good, and get
a new poster.
I'll see you on Tuesday.
Snapchat recipe!
Cut open the squash!
Then you gotta scoopa da goop out!
That looks nice.
Puttin' on SALT.
Then ya flip 'em.
You flip 'em.
Then you remember that you should've started
preheating the oven when-- the first thing,
and you did it, like, the eighth step instead.
Then you gotta put these buddies in the oven.
Put them in the oven, don't burn yourself!
And then be very quiet, for about 45 minutes
while they cook, or else they'll be shy about
cooking.
Thank you, butternut squash, for your life,
and I'm going to consume your flesh.